let's talk about the reputation of the
United States the reputation of the
United States unfortunately and I do I
take no pleasure in this has imploded
over Donald Trump's failure to properly
deal with coronavirus now when Donald
Trump was elected and very clearly was
incompetent and in over his head we
talked about how the leader of the free
world which is not an official title to
Colo colloquial term typically assigned
to the President of the United States
it's sort of like the the major leader
of the Western democracies typically
it's the president of the United States
when Trump was elected widespread
consensus that this is a colloquial
title which shifted to German Chancellor
Angela Merkel and then we saw Donald
Trump essentially remove the United
States from serious participation in one
of the issues of our time climate change
claiming that climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese and pulling the
u.s. out of the Paris climate Accords
and immediately the u.s. became a
non-player in figuring out pollution and
climate change and then I'm skipping
some steps we got to the disaster that
is Donald Trump's response on
coronavirus and when you look at his
actions it makes sense that the
reputation of the United States would
implode Trump didn't take it seriously
from day one Trump was confused and
remains confused about the difference
between a virus and a bacteria and he's
clueless about medicine and pandemics
and he point frankly barely appeared to
care for a very long time while other
countries were actually taking this
seriously he said that the response from
Democrats was meant merely to hurt him
politically and used the word hoax
rather than dealing with the problem
Trump then when he started panicking
realized he had to take it seriously
when and tried to poach a vaccine being
developed in Germany merely for American
use he appears to have interfered with
other countries getting medical supplies
while completely mismanaging our own
national stockpile even having at one
point supplies on route to Thailand
while asking Thailand to send us the
same supplies really the stuff of just
utter utter incompetent management
mismanagement
he had that phase where his focus was
just repeating the phrase Chinese virus
over and over again rather than actually
dealing with anything
he's been promoting unproven treatments
that he talks about as if they are
miracle cures so it's an embarrassment
and he lies every day and the world is
coming to him for help he claims nobody
is coming to Donald Trump for help here
can you imagine something more obviously
untrue the world is going to South Korea
for advice not Donald Trump now look at
the model of South Korea for a moment
South Korea had their first case within
hours of the United States having our
first case South Korea immediately
developed a test and made sure that the
test was widespread and available they
isolated everyone who tested positive or
even had symptoms and a fever
they established fever clinics for
infected people they did extensive
contact tracing and found and isolated
people that were in touch with those
infected and their numbers speak for
themselves we are going to need to do
that to prevent a massive second wave in
the fall South Korea is the country that
did it so now you have what makes sense
you have all sorts of world leaders
saying listen the United States needs to
rethink all of that America first stuff
Stephen Walt who's a professor of
international relations at Harvard says
that not only are Trump's actions
causing death and economic misery they
have tarnished our global reputation
which was already very much damaged
merely by electing Donald Trump in the
first place and from diplomatic
embarrassment after embarrassment
certainly didn't help so let's say
something about the press briefings in
this context Trump does these press
briefings we've been covering some of
them there were no press briefings over
the weekend they're scheduled to get
back underway today those are being
watched by those other countries that
I'm talking about and they are the stuff
of nightmares
other countries see Trump lying
uncontrollably Trump attacking
journalists and a free press Trump
recommending unproven treatments despite
having no medical knowledge whatsoever
Trump saying all of the things that he's
been saying and in the end the saddest
part about all of it is that you
essentially have two different realities
people are watching people are reading
two different books so to speak about
what's going on you have the reaction
from other countries which is this guy
is out of control he's unhinged we need
to stay away and actually deal with
countries that know what they're doing
that's one side and then you've got
Trump supporters that just love it they
watch the press briefings and they see
Trump as tough they see him as
aggressive as a deal maker is not taking
crap from people in the audience as
protecting American interests and being
this heroic Savior by coming to the
American people and telling them go and
try hydroxychloroquine what do you have
to lose despite the fact that there are
significant side-effects and
questionable efficacy every time he
embarrasses himself at one of these
press briefings the world cringes but
his followers get riled up that he's
doing a great job so we are in real
trouble the signs were there for a long
time the kids in cages calling climate
change a hoax you know I could go on and
on lying every day there were signs of
trouble all along but the scariest part
about it is that while the world is
increasingly getting away from the
United States and our reputation is
increasingly a joke not only do the
trumpets love what Trump is doing they
are more confident that Trump is doing
the right thing because the world
cringes at what Donald Trump does they
see it as an endorsement of what Donald
Trump's do is doing and that is one of
the scariest things altogether privacy
calm is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you five dollars just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service i've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman